hey everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the pin knight
trap many times when you play knight to
f3 your opponent's going to get their
bishop pin down your knight to your
queen
and you don't know what to do so we're
going to go over a trap where you can
actually use that to your advantage this
can happen in lots of different openings
i'm going to show it through the lens of
the king's gamut just because i play a
lot of kings gambit and i see it come up
quite often so the king's game it starts
out with e4 e5
f4
and then we are going to look at the
decline line so bishop c5
knight to f3
and then pawn d6 now this is the
preferred method that bobby fischer used
to play
with this d6 opening up for the light
square bishop a lot of players like to
bring their dark square bishop out of
the pawn chain before they play d6
now we are going to play bishop c4
attacking the pawn on f7
and then they're gonna play bishop g4
getting that light square bishop
involved into the game and pinning our
knight to the queen
one thing i always like to do if my
opponent does pin down my knight to the
queen
is look for a strong attack with my
light square bishop on the f7 square now
you can see right now that it would make
a lot of sense for me to take with my
bishop on f7 they could just take and i
don't really have a strong attack if i
just come to
knight g5 check well then they could
just take
with their queen
yes we can take their queen but then
they take our queen and we're gonna end
up
pretty far behind in
material now if you look at where else
the knight can come to it can come to e5
but then they just take with their pawn
that would be ideal
because as soon as we move our knight
there is a discovered attack with our
queen but the problem is this pawn on d6
it's pretty pesky so knowing that's the
idea
we have the move pawn takes e5
and after they recapture with their pawn
we have now laid the trap and so now we
can actually take with our bishop on f7
and if they were to take with their king
now we can play knight takes e5
check
notice that we are moving our knight out
of the way
we are exposing our queen but only if we
can check our opponent
which if your knight is on f3
as soon as the bishop
sacrifices itself on f7 then when you
come up to either e5 or g5 you are going
to be having a discovered attack with
your queen on the bishop and you are
going to be checking that king now if
they don't want to take our bishop
that's completely fine as well they
could come to f8
if you don't want to take our material
that is a-okay with us
we could always bring our bishop back to
b3 we could bring our rook to f1 we have
multiple options
if they don't take our bishop
now if we come back to this situation
you notice that in the king's gambit yes
we have our pawn on f4 and that allows
us to get this defender from a d6 to
exchange on e5 but if you're not playing
the king's gambit how can this come up
well there's a few ways that it could
one is maybe this queen has moved
there's a lot of situations where black
is going to move this queen from d8 and
as long as it's not protecting the g5
square even if this pawn's not here on
f4 you can come up to g5 after the
exchange so exchange right here the
knight comes to g5 and if the queen's
not defending it you still have the same
concept you don't have to worry about
the pawn on d6 moving away because
knight coming to g5 assuming the queen's
not there is check and you have the
discovered attack with the queen so just
always in your games if they try to pin
down your knight to f3 sometimes people
always play you know h3 i gotta kick the
bishop away
see if you have an opportunity to
sacrifice your bishop on f7 and then
move your knight to either g5 or e5
with a discovered attack with your queen
and you may potentially need to do an
in-between move to get that defender
away so you can freely take a piece on
e5 or move to
g5 but hopefully you guys found this
interesting i see it come up quite a bit
hopefully you'll start to see it in your
own games
thank you to our sponsor skillshare if
you're not familiar this is a website
where you can go and take classes on
pretty much any topic that you would
like i'm currently going through one on
mobile app development i get so many
questions about hey can you take the
content on your website and build a
mobile app so i am trying to learn as
much as possible on making that a
reality
if you are someone that can help you can
feel free to reach out to me and let me
know but definitely learning a lot on
this website and skillshare is also
giving to the first thousand people to
sign up using the link below or using my
code
a free 30-day trial so if you want to
support the channel check out skillshare
with that link or the code the chess
website so again skillshare first
thousand people free month thank you
guys so much for watching this video
hopefully you learned something if you
have other topics you want me to cover
feel free to let me know in the comments
below i'll see you guys next time
you